change comes from individual action  people realizing that their voice is  valuable and important and we as  individuals can achieve a lot we have  the power to influence our you know  immediate social circles we influence  those people they can influence people  in their social circles so it's about  working out what we want the future to  look like do we want this future to be a  future which does seek to reduce  suffering that does seek to create  fairer more equal food systems do we  want people to be more empowered to make  individual choices we have the power to  influence change for the choices that we  make and just really important to  recognize that